ما عليك سوى وصف ما نراه الآن
بيكي بيكي ،
حسنًا ، دعني أخبرك بما
تراه ، هذا نادرًا ما
يطلق جولات متعددة من الغاز المسيل للدموع
، لقد تم تحريكه للأمام ، لقد كانت
الرفوف تمطر حوله
، والآن تعود القوات
مرة أخرى.  في السيارة ،
سمعت للتو ما بدا وكأنه
[موسيقى]
مثل الذخيرة الحية المتعددة بالذخيرة الحية وعلى
أي حال ، فإن هذه الصخور تتساقط للتو
وأعتقد أنه في
أي لحظة الآن سيطلق
الغاز المسيل للدموع
وكما كنت أقول في  لقطة مباشرة سابقة ،
لقد كان هذا يومًا
من
الفصول المكثفة عبر الضفة الغربية آه هناك
صخور تتساقط من حولنا شاهد
رأسك
آه وأه نعم إنه مشهد مجنون جدًا
هنا
لأن الغاز المسيل للدموع على الجانب الآخر من
الشارع هبط
المنتج أصيب للتو على
رأسه بالصخرة ولكن لحسن الحظ أنه يرتدي
خوذته وسأضع خوذة
على ريتشارد
للحفاظ على رأس غزاله آمنًا ، لذا نعم
هذا هو المشهد ، فلننتقل قليلاً
لمجرد إلقاء
نظرة ، فالمجموعة الإسرائيلية موجودة هناك
، واه هم الصخور تسير في
اتجاه الإسرائيليين ، فإن الإسرائيليين يردون بإطلاق
الغاز المسيل للدموع ،
واه نعم لم يطلقوا
وابل
الغاز المسيل للدموع  لكن نعم ، حسنًا ، بيكي إذا كان
لديك سؤال ،
اطرح عليه ،
فسأبقى على
هذه الصور
للحظة
بينما أنا وأنت نناقش كما
كنا نفعل الآن على مدار الـ 48
ساعة الماضية
أم تجربتك في
المشاهد  ربما ليس بالضرورة مثل هذا
ولكن تجربتك مع هذه الأعمال العدائية
ومخاوفك بشأن
أين يذهب هذا من هنا
هذا نوع من
لعنة هذه الأرض المقدسة إذا جاز
التعبير جيلًا بعد جيل
متجه للقتال
حتى تصبح هذه المشكلة يومًا ما  تم حلها
وما رأيناه يعود إلى
عام 1993 باتفاقيات أوسلو التي كانت
محاولة توسطت فيها الولايات
المتحدة لحل هذا الصراع بعد بضع
سنوات
انهار ومنذ ذلك الحين بشكل أساسي منذ
الانتفاضة الفلسطينية الثانية  أ التي
اندلعت في سبتمبر 2000
، كان
هناك عنف كان هناك موت على كلا
الجانبين
دمار هائل كانت هناك
بعض المحاولات الفاترة
لحل المشكلة
ولكنها في الأساس
تطول وتطول وبالتأكيد عندما تتحدث  بالنسبة
للأشخاص الذين هم في عمري من كلا الجانبين ، هناك نوع
من الإرهاق
الذي عاشه أطفالهم من
خلال هذا
ومن المحتمل أن أحفادهم سيفعلون
، لذلك من المحزن
أنه بطريقة ما لا يمكن
حل هذه المشكلة ، أعني أن أسباب ذلك
كثيرة ولا أعتقد  لدينا ما
يكفي من الوقت للدخول فيها ولكن
هذا هو الواقع